he helped out financially
George has helped us tremendously and
we're extremely grateful George Lopez
reportedly donated money to help
Prince's family according to several
reports I assisted my brothers at work
and then et has exclusively learned that
Lopez did in fact help the late musician
siblings shortly after news broke that
Prince died I couldn't believe I was in
Columbus Ohio by myself
just days before catching up with the 55
year old comedian at a private memorial
service in Los Angeles held in Prince's
honor et's Michelle Turner sat down with
Prince's eldest half-brother Alfred
Jackson who says his brother meant the
world to him god bless friends god bless
the world that's what I thought of him
as deeply as my brother he's a legend
Lopez also shared fond memories of the
beloved Purple Rain singer know when we
met he wanted to he thought I used
inappropriate language too often and he
wanted to be my Bible teacher and I said
okay because I thought French wants to
give me a Bible a study less I said I'll
do it food poisoning so I couldn't make
it and he said who do you think really
poisoned you so I said okay I thought it
was the rock shrimp of a stuffed
jalapenos but all you might be right it
might have been the guy down below if
that it was the devil keeping us apart
and I and that devil he couldn't keep us
apart so we had some great moments